the hamburg-based group rainforest
rescue is being sued for protesting
against the widespread destruction of
rainforests by the indonesian group
corindo
since 2001 corindo is thought to have
cleared a total of 57 000 hectares of
rainforest in indonesia
that's an area the size of chicago or
seoul
the company rejects accusations that it
systematically cleared forest and
illegally set fires
but not everyone believes that
together with 10 other environmental
organizations rainforest rescue cooled
on german industrial giant siemens and
wind turbine maker nordex to reconsider
their collaboration with corindo in
2016.
almost three years later the tiny german
environmental group was sued for
slandering corindo
rainforest rescue's main concern was
that the lawsuit was aimed not only at
them but at silencing their indonesian
partners too
they are constantly being intimidated by
corindo
it's a company that likes to demonstrate
its far-reaching influence
they're basically saying we can drag
your little partner in germany to court
from indonesia
and you're just small fry
what are you going to do about it
but alarm bells began ringing in hamburg
was this less a case of slander and more
to do with intimidation
often the costs of supplying evidence
for their defense leave small ngos
journalists and bloggers on the brink of
financial ruin
of course it's incredibly difficult
especially when you're trying to get
witnesses from on the ground
we've experienced a huge amount of fear
among those locals who could be
considered as witnesses
if the rainforest rescue group weren't
backed up by evidence from the big
international ngos such as greenpeace
who've published reports and aerial
shots including satellite images
then hands down they'd lose this lawsuit
lawyers for the corindo group responded
to dw's inquiries on the current lawsuit
by saying that it is not up to the court
and the parties involved to decide on
the justification of the claim
in europe there's been a general trend
towards people being brought to court
for publicly raising ecological and
social issues
and that trend has been given its own
name slap
that's an acronym for strategic lawsuit
against public participation
critics say the aim of these lawsuits is
pure intimidation
while the plaintiff has little to gain
journalists and campaigners are simply
worn down through harassment
in 2017 maltese journalist daphne
caruana galicia was killed she'd been
investigating government corruption
reporters without borders say at the
time of her death she was the subject of
40 slap lawsuits
environmental activist carl bear is also
being sued
he'd been campaigning against the use of
pesticides in apple plantations in south
tyrol italy
formerly an employee at the munich
institute for the environment today carl
bear is a member of the german
parliament he's currently facing
defamation charges in a bolsano court
in 2017
baer launched a campaign against the
massive use of toxic pesticides in south
tyrol's apple mono culture
the regional council as well as 1400
apple farmers filed criminal complaints
against him
we initially thought these claims were
part of an election campaign stunt we
didn't think we'd hear any more about
them
then actual charges were brought by the
state prosecutor and there was a
two-year investigation but really it's
an abuse of the legal system because
obviously it was a political issue being
transferred to the legal sphere now it's
being negotiated in court when it really
belongs on the public in parliamentary
scrutiny
carl bear and the environment institute
say they have evidence of every single
pesticide
it's cost a huge amount of time and
money
as well as the costs of travel and
translations bear is living with a
psychological pressure felt by many
others facing similar intimidation
lawsuits
but he says there are many who have it
harder than him
other people such as bloggers who work
unpaid in environmental protection or
anti-corruption are often much worse off
as far as resources are concerned they
end up mentally and financially worn out
by cases like this
intimidation lawsuits like this have yet
another effect anyone with reason to
fear being taken to court will often end
up staying silent or censoring
themselves
it sends a signal to everyone else in my
case that was south chiron
basically they're saying if you stick
your neck out you could end up getting
your head knocked off
the eu commission and the german
government are now trying to stop such
slap lawsuits
it's surprisingly a serious problem
right on the rise we have increased
numbers
especially of cross-border cases so you
as a journalist can be sued in another
member state so it means you have to
hire the lawyers there and to to defend
yourself which is costly which is time
demanding
so the problem is on the rise and uh
we
see that uh
it's part of the political and economic
pressure on media
yes so that's why we decided to
design some legislation but also some
non-legislative actions
vera gerova knows it'll be hard for all
eu members to agree on what defines a
slap lawsuit
some countries after all like to use
such legal measures against undesirable
critics
so when is something slander
when is it justified criticism
it's important that companies must still
be able to take action if false reports
or allegations are made against them
but there are times when this right to
legal recourse is abused as it always
has been and today we're seeing it
happen much more often
so we need a legal framework to end such
processes quickly
so small organizations don't suffer
[Music]
carl bear is glad the issue has finally
been picked up by policy policymakers
but he still faces several years before
his case comes to an end
[Music]
you